iron rusts from disuse
water loses its purity from stagnation even
so does an action sap the vigor of the mind
time stays long enough for anyone who will use it
poor is the pupil who does not surpass his master
there are three classes of people those who see
those who see when they are
shown those who do not see
i am not poor poor are
those who desire many things
our life is made by the death of others
wisdom is the daughter of experience
reprove your friend in secret
and praise him in public
god sells us all things at the price of labor
as a well-spent day brings happy sleep
so a life well spent brings happy death
patience serves as a protection against
wrongs as clothes do against cold
learning never exhausts the mind
tears come from the heart and not from the brain
while i thought that i was learning how to live
i have been learning how to die
the greatest deception men
suffer is from their own opinions
he who walks straight rarely falls
just as food eaten without
appetite is a tedious nourishment
so does study without zeal damage the
memory by not assimilating what it absorbs
marriage is like putting your hand into a bag
of snakes in the hope of pulling out an eel
he who can copy can do he who wishes to
be rich in a day will be hanged in a year
just as courage imperils life fear protects it
he who thinks little airs much
all knowledge which ends in words
will die as quickly as it came to life
with the exception of the written
word which is its mechanical part
he who does not punish evil commands it to be done
it is an acknowledged fact that we perceive errors
in the work of others more readily than in our own
no counsel is more trustworthy than that
which is given upon ships that are in peril
he who does not value life does not deserve it
beauty perishes in life but is immortal in art
he who possesses most must be most afraid of loss
which quote did you like the most
share your opinion in the comments
don't miss out on a chance to
see the next video subscribe